hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from the superbit
chess classic it is round five and we
have alireza firusha taking on the newly
crowned World classical Champion ding
lyron it is an exceptional game you guys
will enjoy it a lot of missed chances on
both sides and the end is not something
that uh well you'd expect after you see
the positions that uh the the end result
basically comes out of uh so let's check
it out alireza has the white pieces and
he opens with Ponte E4 we have something
that we've seen quite a lot pretty much
everywhere and even in the world's
championship match uh bishopter B5 Dory
Lopez is on the board and now Knight to
F6 we have the Berlin defense we have uh
Ponto D3 Bishop to C5 and pawn to C3 we
have Castles by both players and now uh
Ponte D5 something that Nepal also used
against the ding in round seven of the
world's championship match or maybe no
it was around nine uh we have Knight
beta D2 D cap presently for D captures
and now Pawn A5 then goes for the exact
same setup he used against nepo in the
world to championship match in that game
Nepal played Ponte A4 but here alireza
continues with Queen to C2 it is a move
that Magnus Carlsen for example used to
beat the Vladimir kramnik in 2017
but it will also transpose back into the
game that Ding and nepo played in the
world to championship match so Queen E7
we have Pawn to a for now Knight to B8
and now Rook D1 is the move that the
magnets played against the Vladimir
khanik and also that an apple played
against the ding but here we have Pawn
to H3 uh we have rooked the d8 and now
Bishop back to E2 and it is now as of
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how ding continues
with Knight beat the D7 Rook to E1 and
now Knights the f8 we have Knights the
B3 attacking the bishop and C5 Bishop to
B6 and now Knight F the D2 remanuvering
the Knight to C4 to further harass the
bishop with Bishop to E6 and now Knight
the C4 and of course uh adding uh plays
the bishop and E6 to trade it for
Knights of Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now Knight to E6 okay dings
Knights are excellently placed here but
alireza does have the bishop Perry if he
can uh you use that Bishop pair it's
gonna be very nice for him so Pawn to G3
and pawn to H5 now
uh grabbing more space than the king
side preparing uh for uh for for that H4
move to mess up a little as a spawn
structure in front of the king king to
G2 getting out of this nasty diagonal
and now Pawn to H4 with uh Queen to E2
centralizing the queen and now we have
Pawn to G6 now uh the king can come to
G7 in the future because you also want
to get the blacking off of this diagonal
and you can use the H file maybe for the
Rooks if age captures and G4 is possible
so Knights the D2 and now Knight to C5
getting the Knight into the into the
game uh now the Knight is pretty much
stuck here on D2 because if the Knight
moves then you can just capture on e4
but interestingly that's exactly what
alireza does now you might expect
something like G4 here but alireza plays
Knight to F3 and this is where the
position really opens up he's offering
the E4 Pawn uh for some uh incredible
attacking opportunities and okay ding
says uh all right h capital San G3 we're
gonna capture any four but let's start
with the capture on G3 F captures and
Knight C captures on e4 and how can
alireza continue this well there are a
couple of very good options one is G4
the other one is Bishop to A2 and we're
gonna discuss this bishop to 80 move
just tucking that Bishop back for later
use let's say King to G7 and now G4 now
comes Knight to F2 as the Knight is
nicely defended here Queen captures an
E5 winning back the pawn and in now if
we trade let the queen characters Knight
captures on E5 Knight to D3 now offering
a trade of knights Knight Knight
characters Rook captures and now Bishop
to G5 so this is a position that um
could have happened had already gone for
that line he does have the bishop pair
it's a very nice position and uh well uh
it's equalish but you you can always
prefer the bishop pair you know uh you
know from your uh your vast chess
knowledge that as the the game is being
played on both sides of the board having
the bishop pair should be advantageous
for you but alireza went for a
completely different line Knight to G5
uh sort of offers a a trade of knights
but also puts pressure on that F7 Pawn
so you really should trade here but you
could also play something else if you
trade then you develop alirez as Bishop
for free and then the bishop will be
very annoying here so ding just goes
back guards F7 and also puts pressure on
the bishop here Alias and now plays
Bishop to A2 also one of the reasons why
Bishop Tatu in that line was so
impressive as it just uh steps out of
the reach of the Knight and now comes
Rook to E8 biting here ding had this uh
very awesome Ponte E4 move uh problem is
that it's very hard to meet this move
let's say Bishop Dev four you want to
eliminate the defender of the F7 Pawn
now you can play Knight to H5 and now if
you go Bishop captures on D6 with the
thread of uh captures here now you can
play Queen captures on G5 and black is
pretty much winning here uh however he
played Rook the E8 and he allowed being
this um
a very tricky move uh but uh sorry let's
do this I missed it the move is the
bishop to F4 uh you can't really capture
because Queen captures an E7 so you
would have to push now you eliminate the
pawn on D6 and after Queen captures now
you capture an F7 with check and after
King moves you will pick up the Rook
here and okay you win the exchange
playage for Defender Knight here a thing
would have the the central pass Pawn the
bishop is really strong here the Knight
is very nice so I mean the pieces are
are excellently placed but uh uh you
would be down the exchange but he went
for a different line he played H4 first
and now dingoes King to G7 he just gets
the King off of this diagonal and now
Rook the F1 again alireza can play this
bishop therefore move and it is the the
critical line to consider uh but if
Bishop to F4 is played then look at this
Knight F the E4 and now how do you how
do you play this now there actually is a
thread of phone captures Bishop now you
have to play this Knight the E6 check to
cut off the Queen's defense of the pawn
and after F captures an E6 Bishop
captures an E5 with check Knight to F6
and now look at this look at the
spectacular Bishop pair here oh there is
I can play G4 and it would be it would
take an engine
um a precise plate to defend this very
very hard to find moves for black here
uh but alireza played Rook to F1 he once
really wants to put pressure on that F7
pawn and it works out well for him Rook
8 to d8 we have Bishop to D2 and now the
problem is alireza has six minutes on
the clock dink has 22 minutes on the
clock and the ding uses them well Ponte
E4 we have Bishop there for now not
allowing the bishop to be trapped Here
and Now Pawn to E3 all of a sudden dink
has a defended past Pawn on E3 Rook a to
D1 and now uh ding has a a spectacular
move here and it involves uh putting a
knight on D4 which he does only he puts
the wrong Knight on D4 he plays Knight
Dita E4 and the key move to find it was
night after E4 sorry Knight f24 was is
what was played Knight DTE for is what
you should have played it's kinda
counter-intuitive because you also
removed the defender of your F7 Pawn but
the idea is this after Rook capture 78
let's say Rook captures and Bishop
captures on E3 uh there's this very
tricky Knight captures on G3 move
opening up an attack here and you simply
don't care about the F7 Pawn now you
have to play Knight E6 check to cut off
the Queen's attack of the bishop and
after F captures you will play King
captures and G3 Bishop captures Queen
captures and I just Queen the D6 with
check and black is much much better here
as it's very very difficult for for the
white king to find any sort of Refuge so
I have to rotate the one at ding instead
played Knight F the E4 and now it's only
alireza who can win this game and he
finds precise moves First bishop
captures on D6 he removes the defender
of the F7 Pawn Knight captures and now
Bishop captures on F7 as the F7 Pawn was
attacked three times Knight captures
Rook captures and now there's only one
move to play here otherwise you're
getting checkmated and that is Queen
captures on F7 Knight captures an F7
Rook captures on D1 Queen capture Sun D1
and now it seems that the ding got a
whole lot for his Queen because if he
can play E2 then he's winning
uh the problem is if you play Ponte E2
here there's Queen to D7 it's the only
move that wins for white but no doubt
alireza would find it and now you're
really without a move if you promote the
pawn to a queen uh you're getting
checkmate at night the E5 check and your
King has no squares if you go here it's
just a mating one Knights the G4 is
Checkmate and if you go let's say the H6
it doesn't really matter Knights the G4
check again King H5 and now you
sacrifice the Knight and deliver a nice
Queen to G6 Checkmate the king and queen
do a fine job of uh checkmating the
black king here so unfortunately for
ding he cannot uh Advance the pawn to E2
he has to capture the Knight first and
now alireza plays Queen to E2 and
prevents the pawn from a reaching D2
Square which is a light square if he was
allowed to do that then he would uh have
no problems playing this game but now
it's updating and it's only move 36 uh
alireza has two and a half minutes on
the clock ding has five minutes on the
clock and how does uh Dean continue here
well he played King the E7 he wanted to
get get his King to safety and try to
win this game where in fact the the
correct way to play this is King G7 uh
Rook to E7 and try to create some sort
of a fortress there's no winning this
and the problem with Rook to d8 the more
that all of you want to play is that
after King to F1 there's no continuation
for ding even even if you play Rook to
D1 Queen F3 comes with check
uh that's the problem after queen king
to G7 you're gonna capture on B7 and
even if you find this uh E2 uh move e to
checking the one unless it will capture
some B2 there's no way to ever uh
Advance uh from this uh because the Rook
can never move the second rank uh the
king will just capture the pawn it's on
the light score so the dark squirrel
Bishop cannot defend and the white will
just move the queen you don't want to
run into some sort of a silly check so
let's say queen to E4 you prevent Bishop
D3 you prevent everything uh there's no
way to continue here and the pawns will
March forward and um uh Checkmate the
black king so that's the problem uh so
dink right King day seven he wants to
hide the king and then try this idea
because now if let's say Rook to Da
displayed the queen F3 will not come
with the check but all it is not about
to wait for that he plays uh
preemptively King to F1 which is the
absolute strongest move Rook f8 check
King to E1 and now Rook the F2 looks
very scary but there's no way to advance
the pawn to E2 like we've already
discussed Queen to G4 is played and now
just King to F6 defending the G6 Pawn
but Queen to G5 checking F7 and queen to
D5 with check we have King to F6 and now
it is it just plays G4 and now you can
feel the power of these pawns especially
since there's no way to advance 14. uh
Rook captures on video was played Ponto
G5 check King the E7 and now Queen to E5
with check with King to D7 Queen to G7
with check King to D6 and now alireza
just collects the pawn with check with
King the E5 Queen to E8 with check King
to F4 and now Pawn to G6 now the pawn is
becoming a queen and being thought a lot
about this position because time control
has already been reached whether he
should resign he or she should he throw
in a few more checks uh the problem is
even if aldireza plays the absolute
worst moves uh there's there's no bad
Square for the white king Rook to B1
check was played King 32 Rook the B2
checking out you can play anything you
can even play King to D1 if Rook to D to
check you're just gonna put a king and
E1 you can never play Ponte E2 that's
the a horrible truth of the possessions
of King to D3 was played you can play
anything Rook to D2 checking the C4 and
Rook to G2 and now uh Queen to F7 check
and he was in this position and move 52
that World Champ dingler and resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so not only does alireza win
his second game in a row in this
tournament alireza firja is the first
player to defeat dingleren after he
became world champion so that is uh that
is an absolute
um uh you know Triumph that is something
no one can ever take away from him and
it's uh you know it's uh really uh hard
to uh you know uh look at a world
classical Champion you know having four
draws in Road and losing a game uh it's
not something that you would you would
expect out of uh well a world classical
Champion you know when Magnus was
playing in a classical event you it
would be a discussion whether Magnus
with a windy event or he would crush the
event you know okay maybe he doesn't win
an event but usually he does uh but that
that was basically the discussion okay
the tournament is still young anything
can happen but four draws for Ding and
now a loss uh definitely a tough break
for him and also for his chances of
maybe reaching 20 2800 in this
tournament but great stuff for alireza
winning his second game in a row if you
guys are interested I can quickly check
what does this mean for alireza's rating
uh let me just check this real quickly
uh yeah already of course is number two
in the world uh uh goes up plus two
point okay 27.80 87 not uh not
um not very close to 2800 but definitely
getting there
uh so here you resign because uh well
what do you do after King the E4 uh just
Queen to D5 with check loses The Rook or
if you don't if you put the king in
front of the Rook then the pawn can just
advance so there's really nothing to
hope for here so there you have it
alireza first player to crush a world
champion ding lyron we'll see what
happens in the rest of the tournament uh
and we're gonna check at least one more
game and then we are going to discuss
the standings uh so stay tuned for that
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Edmund
Freeman Evan bursty ravishing reptiles
YouTube Lord of Bones and Massey and
alsarak for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful classical event until it
finishes yeah so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day